in this video I want to talk about
post-transcriptional modification so
these are ways in which the RNA that's
been transcribed is modified in some way
so in prokaryotes and eukaryotes they
both have their RNA and tRNA is
processed in a certain way and actually
in pretty much the same way both the our
RNA and the tRNA are cut and trimmed
essentially the initial transcripts are
a little bit too big and so in certain
regions they're cut around and trimmed
to be a little bit shorter no details
really are associated with that at least
I'm not going to talk about them the
tRNA have a further modification there
is an addition of a c c a at the three
prime end so you add a two set of scenes
in an adenine at the three prime end so
if this is a tRNA we're going to be
adding a c a C and an A here at the
three prime end of a tRNA and what's the
reason for that this CCA is important
because it is the attachment site of
amino acids that are going to be
incorporated in translation so amino
acids will actually attach to the CCA
end right here so there be an amino acid
attached there and the tRNA will bring
it to the ribosome for translation but
we'll talk more about that later
now eukaryotes have their mRNA modified
prokaryotes don't so I'm gonna talk
about the eukaryotic mRNA modifications
the first one is the five prime cap and
the five prime cap is a seven methyl
guanosine cap and it's a tad
via a 5 prime to 5 prime triphosphate
linkage what does any of that mean well
the 5-prime indicates that if we have a
particular strand of mRNA the 5 prime
end is going to be capped in some way
that cap is a 7 methyl guanosine and
it's connected via 5 prime to 5 prime
tri phosphate linkage so what does that
look like well if imagine this to be the
mRNA we have the ribose in a base
connect this is the sugar phosphate
backbone here sugar phosphate sugar
phosphate sugar by law and these are the
bases over here so if this is the 5
prime end where these phosphates are
attached to the 5 prime end so if this
is the 5 prime end of a particular
strand what are we going to have well
this here this portion here let me
actually outline it is the 7 methyl
guanosine cap right here ok so why is it
called the 7 if I want to seen well this
portion is the ribose with a guanine
attached to it so that's the guanosine
portion and why is it called 7 methyl
well because if you count if you go
through a number the purine this is this
here this nitrogen is atom number 7 so
that seventh member of the rings has a
methyl attached to it so with a 7 methyl
guanosine and it's attached to the mRNA
strand via a 5 prime to 5 prime tri
phosphate linkage so this ribose is
phosphate groups or this nucleotide
support this guano scene is attached to
this ribose right it was five prime
phosphate attached to this platform
phosphate so then there's three of these
phosphates here so that is a 5 prime to
5 prime linkage and there are 3
phosphates what is the purpose of this
five prime cap well does a few things
first is that it aids in transport from
the nucleus to the cytoplasm or the
cytosol that's important right because
in eukaryotes transcription occurs in
the nucleus another thing that it does
is that it protects
the 5-prime end from degradation by
nucleases if you recall nucleases
breakdown nucleic acids so any
exonucleases that want to act on this
end here won't be able to because of
this five prime cap another thing that
it does is that it promotes the binding
of the mr of MVM RNA transcript to the
ribosome for translation so the mRNA
needs to be translated right that's the
purpose of mrna so it needs to be
translated on a ribosome well it needs
to somehow bind the ribosome
so this five-prime cal perhaps five
prime cap helps that do that another
modification is a three prime let me
actually write it in blue a 3 prime poly
a tail so poly lots of adenine czar
attached to the 3 prime end so it's a
poly a tail and it's attached by poly
adena late polymerase that makes sense
it's the thing that adds a bunch of it
pays on it so if this is a 5 prime end
of an mrna this is 3 prime end we add a
bunch of editing debates ID number the
letter n here to represent a certain
number of nucleotides being added what's
the purpose of this 3 prime poly a tail
essentially it protects the 3 prime end
from degradation oops that's messy from
degradation and usually there are about
like 100 to 300 a's that are added to
that 3 prime end the third modification
to mrna in eukaryotes is splicing the
mRNA transcripts are spliced this is
carried out with this thing called the
spliceosome spliceosome
which contains these things called
schnapps SN R NP schnapps
okay that's a funny name I actually
enjoy saying it slurps that stands for
small nuclear rnas and proteins
so when splicing occurs is this thing
called a lariat structure that's formed
and I'll show you what that looks like
in just a second but what's happening in
splicing is that there are these things
called introns and there are these
things called exons so introns are
intruders so what happens to them is
they are cut out don't let that confuse
you exons are exceptional right there
are the exceptions
oops
I can just write exception exceptions or
exceptional however you want to remember
it but these exons they stay in so the
introns are spliced out the exons stay
in how does that actually happen well if
we have for instance a pre mRNA or an
immature M mRNA with exon number one
here and some intron and then exon
number two on these introns are these
certain branch points now what these
branch points are involved in is the
formation of a lariat the library
structure that I'm about to show you so
this branch point what happens is it's
two prime OAH right on the ribose ring
of a certain Dhupia tied over here is
going to go over and nucleophilically
attack here at the it's going to attack
with the nucleotide over here on the
intron that's attached to exon number
one and when it does that it bonds to
itself and that's what this is it kind
of loops around formed this little
actually probably shouldn't have drawn
that arrow in that color so as to not be
confusing we draw like this in blue so
buying
there and it forms it kind of loops
around like this and binds itself at
that branch point so that branch point
here is right there
then exon number one now has free three
prime OAH group now what happens to that
is that 3 prime MOH group goes ahead and
it nucleophilically attacks here at the
exon to cause this lariat so let me
actually label that this lariat
structure of the intron - to break off
and then the exon one gets to connect
exon 2 so what happens is the exon
number one and exon number 2 become
connected and then this lariat structure
dissociates away so now we went from a
pre-mrna or immature RNA to a spliced
and mature mRNA so that's how slicing
works now maybe you thought about this
earlier but why don't prokaryotes have
post-transcriptional modifications of
mrna well to answer to that we have to
answer these questions here so do
prokaryotes have a nucleus no two
eukaryotes have a nucleus yes now where
does transcription occur in each of
these types of cells or each of these
classes in prokaryotes transcription
occurs in the cytosol the reason why is
because prokaryotes do not have any
membrane bound organelles they don't
have a nucleus in eukaryotes
transcription does occur in the nucleus
now where does translation occur
translation occurs in the cytosol in
both of them prokaryotes and eukaryotes
in procures by default really because
they have no place other than the
cytosol for things to happen new
carry-outs translation occurs in the
cytosol transcription occurs in the
nucleus now why is this important
because in prokaryotes and eukaryotes
but think about what about the timing of
transcription and translation well in
prokaryotes
transcription occurs in the cytosol
translation occurs in the cytosol so as
soon as an mRNA is transcribed the
ribosomes in the cytosol can hop right
on and begin translating away so the
timing in prokaryotes is at the same
time so essentially what's going on it's
actually a little bit messy sorry about
that at the same time so the mRNA
doesn't have a chance to get modified it
doesn't have time to get modified
because as soon as it's transcribed it
begins to be translated because the
ribosomes are in the cytosol and
eukaryotes however is a little bit
different the transcription occurs in
the nucleus so the mRNA is made in the
nucleus and it has to leave the nucleus
to go to the cytosol and then be
translated so here there are different
times because the mRNA has to leave the
nucleus to the nuclear pores and then
enter into the cytosol so then
translation can occur so because the the
mRNA sort of separated from the cytosol
by the nuclear membrane here there is
time for modifications essentially so
that's subtle difference of you know the
presence or lack thereof of a nucleus is
important in answering this question
here and I hope that made sense I hope
this video was helpful in understanding
these topics one last thing I am a tutor
if you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at move
University as email comm see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching